je vous laisse vous installez bien
confortablement éteindre vos lumières et
se passe
[Musique]
j'aime bien en fait c'est avoir de la
diversité du coup pouvoir va faire un
jour un tueur en série puis un autre
jour une disparition puis un autre jour
des fois je fais même des vidéos plus
générale où je vais aborder carrément
par exemple les tueurs en série ou les
tueurs de masse et plus avoir ce côté un
peu court sur comment ça fonctionne de
manière globale
il a aussi reçu énormément de lettres de
femmes qui sont amoureuses de lui
ça c'est quelque chose d'assez
particulier qui s'appelle libristes au
fini c'est à dire la très amoureux ou
sexuelle pour les tueurs en série le
point de départ souvent c'est par
exemple la page wikipedia ça me donne
une bonne idée de la chronologie ensuite
je vais voir en bas toutes les sources
jose tous les articles je vais les lire
je vois quelles sont les informations
qui reviennent celles qui sont en
contradiction parce que souvent sur
internet
bah on n'a pas toujours la même version
d'une histoire donc le but c'est
d'essayer d'amasser le plus
d'informations possibles vraiment je
creuse je lis toutes les pages internet
tous les articles qui ressorte il ya des
vidéos des reportages si jamais un livre
parfois ça peut être vraiment
intéressant de pouvoir lire le livre
s'il a été écrit par un des
protagonistes par exemple moi je suis
pas journaliste je me positionne pas en
tant que journaliste sur youtube
maintenant je me positionne et j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais c'est à dire
une étudiante en criminologie maintenant
diplômés en fait en tant que psychologue
en tant que criminologue togo n'est pas
véritablement dans un dédoublement de la
personnalité mais par contre on est
carrément dans ce qu'on appelle en
criminologie le clivage
du plus loin dont je me rappelle et j'ai
toujours aimé les histoires bail que
j'appelle glauque mois donc au début
quand j'étais vraiment petit c'était des
histoires de monstres de fantômes de
sorcières etc
et puis quand j'ai un petit peu plus
grandi je dirai quand je suis arrivé au
collège je me suis intéressé aux
affaires criminelles
parce que ma mère regardait beaucoup de
documentaires sur les affaires
criminelles françaises donc j'ai écouté
avec elle et puis après c'est la
psychologie qui s'est rajouté et puis il
envie de comprendre de ses d'expliquer
voire de prévenir certains phénomènes
moi ce que j'aime bien aussi c'est
apporter mes connaissances en tant que
psychologue parce que du coup bah c'est
pas forcément à la portée de tout le
monde et j'essaye de les rendre plus
accessibles et puis surtout d'être la
plus pédagogue possible pour ce soit
quand même
facilement écoutable par tout le monde
au delà de raconter les faits je sais
que les gens aiment bien ça pour voir un
petit peu aller au delà trouver une
question qu'on peut se poser ou dire
cette histoire là qu'est ce qu'on peut
en apprendre est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose qu'on peut en ressortir
est ce que ça peut nous faire nous
questionner je ne sais pas moi sur
comment notre système judiciaire traite
certaines affaires comment est-ce qu'on
aurait un cerf l'x les criminels comment
est ce que on s'occupe des victimes fin
il ya toujours un petit truc en plus à
aller creuser et je trouve que c'est ça
qui donne aussi battre de l'intérêt
parce que sinon c'est juste pour parler
d'une histoire comme je disais il suffit
d'aller lire la page wikipedia et puis
voilà on les a laissés